hello,
My name is Philipp martmann and I am the
european candidate
for The Greens in Münster.
Agriculture
and nature conservation
are 2 very central concerns for us green ones.
we want to create 1 system in agriculture,
what us humans
can eat healthy and healthy food
creates for everything.
But we also want to create agriculture,
which is fair for the people who consume,
but also for the people who work in agriculture
work and produce there.
we want to have agriculture,
which in accordance with
with social standards and with nature is.
Nature conservation is the 2nd important issue at this point.
we want to expand and expand the green deal.
1 Green deal that protects nature,
protects our livelihoods and thus ourselves.